[Music]
lady why am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question um well actually
not just one I have all the questions
who wants to go on a road trip you need
help with that no no I got it
I know this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
four key but we get quite Roger that
[Music]
change of plans Jessie but Bo Rex potato
hey watch it buddy
oh let's go save a spork do I need to be
worried
my guys are veteran so hang in there
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man oh
yeah posing yeah hold on one more oh
yeah I've known that guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside so
much body needs for kids Oh Sheriff
would you always come in to the rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
do for me
[Music]
let's kaboom
for he's being kept how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go oh where did you come from well
we're not doing that I know you're
trying to get money in the trouble now
of course not it could have been
confiscated let me take it away you
could have been lost no no no guys
listen Bonnie had a great day in class
and we're going on a road trip road trip
big JJ did something really weird
happened Bonnie made a friend in class
oh no no she literally made a new friend
hey it's okay
come on out that's it
[Music]
come let's get you out of there you got
this good everyone I want you to meet
[Music]
hey hey sorry to bother you but why
you're not a father at all we were just
out for my early morning stroll and look
we met you my name is Gabby Gabby and
this is my very good friend Vincent Oh
woody pleasure to meet you well it's
nice to meet you woody and you are this
is for ki I'm trashed our kid made him
kid toys around here don't have kids are
you two lost lost no but we are looking
for a lost toy
she's a figurine used to be on that lamp
in the window name's Bo Peep Bo Peep oh
yes I know Bo you do hop on in we'll
take you to her oh you don't have to do
that okay Vinson be careful with our new
friend like you
hey up here astro boy if you think you
can just show up and take our top prize
spots your room dead wrong you don't
understand I'm trying to get a system
and get with the kid yeah we no no I
need a child to shower you with
unconditional love
join the club join the club come on help
me get out of here
I'll help you with my foot give him cold
ghetto a bunny what are you doing hmm I
can't reach him help me out here come on
oh sorry ducky I'm not a mind-reader you
know what what's not to understand hmm
you maybe say it what with these tiny
legs I cannot reach without your help oh
all right okay this is what I've been
talking about money you need to work on
paying attention and your listening
skills ha
hi Duke who's the cowboy Duke meet woody
woody me Duke kaboom Canada's greatest
stunt man oh yeah huh Duke Duke we need
one more oh yeah
what brings you back wow this place is
amazing what a buzz gonna meet us here
he must be held up somewhere hey up here
Astro Boy if you think you can take our
top prize spot your room dead wrong help
me get out of here you're kidding me he
said that to your face to my face I know
what happens I get real close right I'm
like I don't care which Cabbage Patch
you're from Oh give me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face you are I don't care bear
you see the new movie trailer for what
you ain't see it what what is it ducky
but they're making another Toy Story
movie now I thought those movies would
dawn dog they made three movies Tim make
three movies this is number four Oh toy
stories - yeah what about Buzz Lightyear
stuff I am Buzz Lightyear Space Ranger
what is like to infinity and your mom
that's not right you sure no that's not
right pretty sure that's it let me show
you to insanity and blonde what do you
even know - immunity and respond
hey guys you got it all wrong it's to
infinity and beyond go to infinity
dummies it's impossible so when was the
first time you guys met
I don't recall the first time meeting
you that was so long ago
do you have been buzzed for what 45
years I don't know so we don't
necessarily say hey how you doing we
just sitting down and starting getting
in it's almost this relationship in a
weird way whoa you need help no I got it
now we end up sort of like speaking the
secret language buddy it's Bo Peep what
are you doing here one word to describe
each other skilled cranky Wow
next question you're kidding who has the
better catchphrase woody or Buzz oh come
on to infinity and beyond if you got it
that's one of the greatest lines ever
written in the show to infinity I have
to say buzz got that into the deal oh
but I have the most fabulous line you
could ever have come on guys come on
guys it guys come on guys listen it
talked about the beginnings of Woody and
Buzz all I remember saying was this is a
great story I mean it was a great story
from the very first moment of the very
first Toy Story there is a comforting
relationship that you have with these
toys and it continues Toy Story 4 is a
transition to a much bigger world
I love these characters yeah what I will
say woody found a great friend in buzz
and Thomas found a great
totally great outdoors our friendship
and I thank you too for getting these
two girls on my way woody everyone
Bonnie made a friend in class oh she's
already making friends no no she
literally made a new friend I want you
to meet porky he's a spool yes yeah I
know
for ki is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him
woody we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was paper soup salad maybe chili and
then the trash but we've gotta get
worked up urban
why am i alive
you're Bonnie's toy you are going to
help create happy memories that will
last for the rest of her life
huh Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kids room when you can have all
of this Wow woody are we going to Bonnie
we have to find that we do but what
would would he do jump out of a moving
vehicle let's go hey we gotta go you
gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home
on my way what is infinity and beyond
kids lose their choice every day I was
made to help a child I remember it being
this hard weddy somebody's whispering in
your ear
[Music]
both of angel
and ice-cream castle
[Music]
and everywhere
I looked at cars up where
but now
we block the Sun hey ray
so
means I would
good
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
Gally
hey somebody get down before coaching I
am
[Music]